[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
ali settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what well you know i first
i met steven spielberg in that in that
uh meeting i've bored you i've told you
about this before but we met at amblin
and he said you know
nice to meet you and your part
your part has been um is now in question
you may not be in the your character may
not be in the movie if i told you this
no this is true he said i think you're
this the alan grant character may
include all of that characters from the
books lines and i said gee
how can i
what can i say you know i'm sure i
didn't influence him at all but anyway
things changed i got in the movie that's
that then that's the last time i saw him
before we showed up in hawaii
because he was out doing something else
or something and he doesn't like to
rehearse and and we sent him pictures of
the costume which i kind of bought you
know pieces of that and then the first
day of shooting i saw him
and uh as i remember we didn't have any
big discussion about you know here's the
movies about the movies but nothing
about that my first day shooting with
we're shooting joey mazzella getting
fried on the wire
all that stuff i didn't know that was
your first stage that was the first day
shooting and um
so that's alan grant's first appearance
i've got like three lines or something
and i've been doing this american accent
for some weeks preparing for this
and after the first couple takes stephen
comes up to me says
sam you know that um you know that
accent you're doing
let's forget about it and and just just
use your own voice just use your own
voice i said thanks stephen that's great
so anna grant you know comes from
australia or new zealand or something
i'm really relaxed
and i use my own voice for three days
and and then about three days later he
comes back to me and says
you know that voice you're using now i
said yeah yeah my voice he said
just somewhere in between
that's that now i didn't know that alan
grant has a kind of a mishmash accent
and and the way i rationalize it is he's
not really america well he's american
but he's spent some time in australia
i wanted to ask wasn't our first day
together
with sir richard
when
we're at the pin and we see the empty
when they've lowered the goat down and
they bring it back up wasn't that our
first day as a group lower the cow
that's that festival that's our first
stage was it yeah that's my favorite
memory our first day all of us together
because we had we had rehearsed or
worked on some rewriting or writing
of
scenes to sort of establish our
relationship remember yeah
um so we'd spent a little bit of time um
with stephen doing that and then we were
all there together and we had that first
and i've told this story before in front
of you guys i know but we've we had that
first shot all of us together
where we're supposed to
hear and then see the rustling and
suddenly there's a sound
and we all have this look to camera
together
and action
and suddenly i look and then sam and
then jeff and then sir richard no one's
consistent and he says cut cut you guys
i have to have you all turn and look at
the sound and when you hear the sound
it's the first time we hear a dinosaur
and we said stephen please can you
help us and he goes i've got it i've got
it
remember and he said action
and we're there and it's so exciting
we're in this movie and we're gonna have
dinosaurs come to life again and the
audience is going to be with us and
stephen with a megaphone
rawr
rawr
and we all lost it and thought it was
going to be a disaster
i don't think they did it on our movie
but i had a little part on that fallen
kingdom movie and i hadn't been in a
dinosaur movie since you know way back
in the 90s and
j.a beona was on a soundstage and they
were doing chris pratt and isabella's
sermon we're doing something and
because i'm reminded of what stephen had
done all those years ago they had some
great sound system in the on the sound
stage where not only they were playing
music he had a whole playlist of you
know partly the jurassic john williams
stuff but other movies scary things
beautiful so you were already
and then in the scene
big dinosaur sounds that were shaking
the chair and shaking your bones so they
were acting to that dr grant
my dear doctor
welcome
to jurassic park
well i'm proud to say
not only do we
not know what people would you know feel
about the film but we certainly
had no idea what the film was or what we
were looking at or what it would sound
or look like and we mostly were looking
at an x up in a tree and hearing stephen
make a dinosaur a lot of it was ccgi but
some was stan winston stan winston who
won an oscar for that and the raptors
were terrifying uh those were all made
beautifully and of course the uh
triceratops that was fantastic it was
right there and the puppeteers were off
couldn't even see them they were in some
little
underneath something so you came upon
this thing on the set it was breathing
and blinking and you know it was creepy
and sweet yeah yeah and the whole pile
of dung was steaming but what did they
use for that actually
no no
none of us could know this this would be
so iconic that we'd be here in 30 years
you could you couldn't have predicted
that not for a moment but that michael
creighton book was a it was popular and
fantastic and steven spielberg you know
was a mm-hmm who knows how to make
movies but the big breakthrough was the
dennis mirren was the cgi stuff
incredible they signed up to do that
book uh before they could do it stephen
had said to kathleen kennedy uh as the
story goes we need i need these
dinosaurs to be running she said well
like yeah i've talked to theme park
people and you know uh we can't we can't
do that and things went developed and
they could and then dennis meuron said
come here i want to show you something
and for the first time ever he said
watch this computer look what we kind of
have fashioned
and apparently that day kathleen and
everybody stood up and were like you
by
jove you've done it this is incred it
was like people have said was like when
sound first came into movie making and
it has changed and that was a day and
that movie because and we couldn't have
known no way but it would work
i was really moved by it you know i
think stephen is such a master and we
were so fiercely committed to what they
were all describing
everyone together was going to create in
combination and particularly with this
new venture of cgi and this this
division camera we'd never seen before
and
you know giant laptops being like kind
of wheeled onto set so that we can sort
of remember all that was so crazy but it
felt like
honestly like a pioneered indie movie
it didn't feel like we were making a
blockbuster and so we knew our job was
to keep it as
hopefully as authentic
and
and
you know that we carried the awe of this
experience even though you know it was
imagination that we were using that you
know you hoped it would come together
but of course stan winston's work was so
awe inspiring helped us so much as well
that is one big pilot
well i'm i'm a giant fan of both of
these these are you're talking to
not me on either side of me are the two
international treasures and two premier
actors of their generation or of any
time and so they're whole ubras both of
them there's so many moments from both
of their works but in the jurassic
movies oh my golly i love sam watching
ian malcolm
with my hand doing the experiment
with this obvious
flirtation and science lesson that's
happening at the very beginning of the
movie
the looks on sam's face
the alan grant that we got to experience
all over again this last couple of years
so amazing yeah well i like that first
scene that we find ourselves together in
the helicopter and uh
i say so you two you two uh dig up dig
up dinosaurs
he goes in this virile
and wonderful way he goes
we try
something like that okay my my two
favorite jeff and laura moments with
laura is dragging her which she's half
and she's just covered in mud
and she's she's gonna get she's gonna
and she screams and no one screams like
lauren
just the full commitment to the full
screen you know
and by contrast
jeff
it's looking at an enormous pile of
dinosaur
poo
and says something like that's one big
pile of poo is it
the s-h-i-t
so he managed to they managed to make it
funny and cool at the same time
with his shades you know it was it was
quintessential goldblum yeah so there's
two two quintessential little snapshots
i have in my head of
jeff and lauren did we shoot that in
hawaii or do we shoot that and why why i
remember that day yeah yeah i remember
that day we only spent two weeks in
hawaii the first for the first one like
that and then we shot here and then we
were here but two weeks the first two
weeks of that show we were in hawaii i
remember those balmy breezes and uh you
know ultimate hurricane
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
well the first thing we did
after being apart for 25 years was
literally move in together for months
the very first moment with our luggage
going we're
entering a home
uh we were all in this uh we can say now
the yeah langley hotel which is near
pinewood studios where we shot it and we
all literally you know we were exclusive
we it was just us there
cruising about it was like four months
like that all like that and the first
moment i i remember i pulled up from the
airport i hadn't seen them maybe we
talked once on the phone and the
lead-ups
i pulled up with my and they'd already
gotten there a few couple days before a
few days before or a week before i
pulled up and they had figured out when
i was arriving and it's a grand
structure they were on the kind of this
balcony overlooking this driveway where
i was pulling up and they both were
there to kind of
greet me it was kind of fantastic and
then the first thing we shot
in this movie if anybody has seen it or
hasn't seen it yet is when the three of
us are in
uh a
a vehicle i'm driving and i won't tell
you what happens or if you've seen it
but we have this big big scene the first
thing we did all together we had to
improvise a little bit
[Music]
must go faster
i want to tell you about the the most
fun we ever had
and that's why i was looking forward to
us coming back together we were shooting
in hawaii in this in this hotel full of
tourists
and we were shooting different scenes
from from the film and you probably
remember in the first film jeff gets
half eaten by a dinosaur and he breaks
his leg and he's
he's he's he's like it's covered in
stuff
and we'd have to come back to the hotel
at night and get our makeup off and get
you know get get
shower all this stuff off and we used to
enjoy coming through the through the
lobby no one knew who
who we were but we were all
we'd come back all trashed because we'd
been through
dinosaur stuff covered in blood
but most particularly jeff who had one
leg and a splint
he you know comes to the lobby like this
and and um
just for fun just for the tourists we
said you'll walk properly walk probably
and we kick him in his leg
they go ah
and and the japanese tourists are
absolutely horrified by this behavior
but that was that was the stuff we would
do at night it was it was just
stuff all sorts of high jinks like that
yeah there's no stopping us stupid stuff
and um uh we still do stupid stuff to
this to this day to this very day to
this very day i remember what what hotel
did we stay at do you remember the name
of that it got trashed in the it was
right hotel niki you know we lived
through a horrible thing and but we
survived the hurricane
yes you know hey have i haven't told you
you know i've had people in the last
year say you know you guys were very
lucky we now know that the whole there
was a hurricane iniki and four people
died on the island it was all the whole
thing was trashed but they they they
protected us all by going on into a
lower level in the hotel we were at and
all getting our
the ball room
and we made it out okay we started peek
peeked through and the next day was all
trash but somebody said oh no if there
had been a tsunami or something that you
had that would have been the wrong
choice you could have all been worst
place that's a bad place to go down to
go down we were in a basement we were
like
no we're not a basement but we're about
five
feet above sea level we should have we
should have gone uh it was a bad place
to be but we remember talking to richard
attenborough and we say
do you think we might die today richard
this is this is pretty bad he said
darling
i lived through the blitz
he'd been bombed by the luftwaffe and we
covered him in this little blanket and
he took a nap while we were all crying
and screaming
[Music]
you